Look, eh, the reality is that
if you talk about spirituality,
spirituality informs your morality,
your character as a person.
Now, that is why you find that
in a country whereby you've got politicians,
and the past 30 years or so has shown how
once you've got politicians
or leaders that are not founded on a higher power,
a divine power,
those leaders are most likely not to have the certain
values that are needed to lead society,
values such as Ubuntu.
Now, once you do not,
once you have leaders that do not have Ubuntu,
you're going to have high levels of corruption,
high levels of Ubuntu that only think about themselves
but did not think about the,
the, the other person.
Because Ubuntu is a value system that says
you are as a person
because of other people.
Meaning if you become a leader,
you are a leader
because you ought to serve other people.
So in our view as a ATM,
we need to be very strong on spirituality
because we need to have a strong,
we need to have strong
leaders that are founded on a divine power
that can guide their conscience.
Because, you know,
once you talk about umbilin,
umbilin becomes that thing
when you're about to do something wrong,
we have a voice in you that says,
Erongolando Zion's.
But in the absence of spirituality,
then you do not have leaders that have got a conscience,
leaders that do not have a conscience
Are leaders that will lead the nation astray,
leaders that will be corrupt,
leaders that will not act in the best
interest of the people.
And this is what we see currently in our country.
I think that's all well and good
and many people would agree with that.
But to what extent then
does the actual act of introducing
further aspects of religion into the state play out?
To what extent are you proposing
for more deep seated changes to our Constitution
or our policy landscape to actually
explicitly include religion?
Look, um, I would like to use the word spirituality
instead of religion.
Now, spirituality
in our view is, um,
you know, is the, the,
the programs or the act of building one's character.
Um, because once you talk about spirituality,
talking about the, the,
the, the value systems,
if, for example,
you go to our schooling,
our schools,
particularly the ones in the townships and the villages,
you find that there was biblical studies
that were there
because they were set out to build the character
of the children in the particular schooling system.
Now, what the government did was to withdraw
that program that was there to build a character
but did not introduce anything.
Therefore, when you see the high levels of crime,
the high levels of intolerance,
the high levels of moral degeneration
amongst our young people,
we need to ask ourselves,
what are we practically doing as a country
to grow a nature
Good morals and a good character in our society.
And, you know,
you'd call that in 2021,
there was the,
the unrest in Kaizer
and in some parts of Gauteng.
Um, you know
what the government did?
They actually asked religious
leaders to actually go to people and,
you know, um,
go to a number and
so that people do not go out, um,
to, to, to, to,
to loot and etcetera,
which clearly shows that the government
does see the value of, um, our,
our, our spiritual leaders
because without spiritual leaders,
then you are going to have more criminals,
you are going to have
more people that are not going to abide by the law.
But once you've got more people,
spiritual leaders
that are educating people as to how to coexist,
how to, um, behave well in a society,
how to respect some of the laws,
how to even respect the government,
then you are going to have a much more safer
and just, um,
just society
because the people are going to be able to coexist.
You are not going to have these high levels of crime.
So, for us as a ATM,
we view that the, critically,
the most important thing that ought to be done
is to build the character of our nation
so that we have it
an identity.
And for that to happen,
we need to be based on spirituality,
African spirituality,
to be more precise.
So, it's well known that the South African.